Why did we not figure out earlier
that t-models were effective?
Many reasons, but mostly because
t-models only really shine if you
have enough data to train them.
It's only in recent years that large
enough data sets have made their way to
the academic world.
We'll look at another reason now,
we know better today how to train very,
very big models using better
regularization techniques.
There is a general issue when you're
doing numerical optimization which I
call the skinny jeans problem.
Skinny jeans look great,
they fit perfectly, but they're really,
really hard to get into.
So most people end up wearing
jeans that are just a bit too big.
It's exactly the same
with deep networks.
The network that's just the right
size for your data is very,
very hard to optimize.
So in practice, we always try networks
that are way too big for our data and
then we try our best to
prevent them from overfitting.